i think the first thing you do is get
major lectin containing foods out of
your diet
most people even within a couple weeks
begin to notice a difference
how could a diet be negatively affecting
your longevity if it makes you feel
better
it makes your sleep better if it
improves your heart rate variability if
it makes you stronger
most people are working all day and
they're sad and they feel like
and when you get out there you're like
wendy's drive-through come on baby
hit me up with one of them double
cheeseburgers
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life
and learn how to fix your diet
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get lectins out of your diet with dr
steven gundry
lectins are plant proteins that are one
of the major defense
systems of a plant against being eaten
one of the things that's hard for us
to con conceptualize is that plants do
not want to be eaten
they actually have a life and they were
actually here first
when insects arrived plants had a
problem because
they couldn't run they couldn't fight
they couldn't hide
but they have a huge advantage and
that's their chemist
they can turn sunlight into matter and
we haven't figured out how to do that
yet
so what they do is they make proteins
that are sometimes called sticky
proteins or lectins
that stick to certain sugar molecules
in us particularly in our gut lining
just by the way if
anybody has sinusitis or runny noses
when they eat certain foods
you are actually producing sugar
molecules in your mucus to trap
lectins and i have so many people who
had chronic sinusitis including myself
when we finally got lectins out of our
diet they completely went away
so lectins bind to sugar molecules
lectins cause the wall of our gut
to actually separate and people have
heard the term leaky gut
i used if you'd asked me 15 years ago if
i
thought leaky gut was was a problem i
would have said it was pseudoscience
now with the advances in understanding
how the microbiome works and in
understanding how lectins work
i think everyone who has a disease
has a leaky gut now i'm pretty dumb
hippocrates said this 2500 years ago
that all disease begins in the gut so
one of the things we know about research
is research is
research look again because somebody
already knew this
and hippocrates knew it 2500 years ago i
think the first thing you do
is get major lectin containing foods out
of your diet
you won't like me for a couple weeks but
most people
even within a couple weeks begin to
notice a difference now
what are those they're foods that we
actually evolutionary were not designed
to eat
beans are so lethal raw that there's
very good published studies in humans
that they can cause
massive bloody diarrhea and there's some
pretty good studies
in monkeys rhesus monkeys and red velvet
monkeys that they can actually cause
heart disease and even kidney damage
from the lectin content
what's fascinating from a human
evolution standpoint
is that humans up until the dawn of
agriculture
were actually very tall creatures most
humans were about six feet tall
and our brain size was about 15 percent
bigger than it is today
and when if you look chronologically by
8 000 years 2000 years
into grain and bean eating we actually
shrunk about a
foot and our brain size has never
recovered
from 10 000 years ago so these are
anti-nutrients grains and beans that's
number one
number two 2 000 years ago
northern european cows suffered a
genetic mutation
spontaneous mutation where they stopped
making the normal protein in milk casein
a2 and began making casein
now casein a1 has a lectin-like protein
that is converted into a compound called
beta-caseomorphine
which can cause a direct immunologic
attack on the beta cell of the pancreas
the
insulin producing cell in the pancreas
and there's some pretty good evidence
and it's accumulating every
every year that one of the causes of
type 1 diabetes or juvenile diabetes
is casein a1 milk and it actually
correlates very well
in countries that have casein a1 cows
they have
much higher incidence of type 1 diabetes
than countries that have caseinated 2
cows
cheeses for instance are safe from
france italy and switzerland
sheep goats and water buffalo are all
casein a2
and what is it about that that's so
problematic it actually makes a
it's a lectin-like compound that
stimulates an immune response
so just as i would get from the beans or
whatever
exactly you'll get the same thing okay
so it's a it's a very new addition to
our diet
now the newest addition to our diet
is some of our most precious
foods are american north american or
south american
foods for instance in the nightshade
family potatoes
eggplant peppers tomatoes and goji
berries
so the night shades the peel and the
and the seeds have the lectins and
native american indians
in the southwest always peel and de-seed
their peppers they char their peppers
they de-seed them
and then they either grind it into chili
or eat them that way but they always
do that the italians
always peel and de-seed their tomatoes
before they make sauce
and is this like a cultural intuition
kind of thing were they
well what i like to do is i go around
the world studying cultures and figuring
out
why did they do this how did they
detoxify
lectins for instance rice was
invented eight thousand years ago four
billion people use rice as their staple
yet four billion people take the hall
off of rice and eat it
white and surely there can't be four
billion dumb
people who don't know any better that
white rice is bad for them and brown
rice is good for them
in fact they've been taking the hall off
of
rice for 8 000 years same way
believe it or not up until william
and william and harvey kellogg in the
early 1900s
did the idea that whole grains were good
for us
and if you look back 50 years
and when the whole grain goodness really
caught on
you'll notice that a lot of our current
health issues including this
epidemic of autoimmune disease didn't
occur
this epidemic of dementia didn't occur
and so whole grains are one of those
wonderful myths that got perpetrated by
a few individuals
rule number two lean towards balance
with joe rogan
you see a direct correlation between the
amount of refined sugars and
carbohydrates
human beings have adjusted and started
eating to the rise in diabetes and heart
disease and all these other issues
and you know the one of the things we
were talking about before the podcast is
sorry i went running today for some
reason i can't stop coughing
people are dealing with
a lot of various health issues and
they're always trying to pin
like one cause of these heart health
issues yeah and one of the real problems
is when people
develop these ideological answers like
veganism is one of them
they do not want to think that there's
anything healthy about meat
and that what they do is the only way
and this is the way and like i'm
watching this there's a thread right now
going on on twitter
between some cockamamie vegan doctor
he's full of and all these people that
are
citing science and and he is getting
pissed off and he's showing his degree
and photos of his degree now like look
for this real science to the fact that
dietary cholesterol is necessary
it's it's the building blocks for cells
i mean it literally is
it's the the it's the reason why
your body is converting it to all the
sex hormones
cholesterol saturated fat your body
processes that
it's healthy for your brain it's healthy
for your heart all these things are a
fact
he's not recognizing the fact that the
issue
is not saturated fat it's saturated fat
in conjunction
with all these other things that's a
problem with these studies like one of
the studies they did recently
where they showed that people who ate
meat more than five times a week were
much more likely to have heart disease
but that's not a good study because they
didn't say what are they eating the meat
with
yeah what else what are you eating the
meat with what's there yeah are you
eating it with bread
are you eating it you know as a burger
are you drinking a soda with it
right like this is not a good study a
good study would be
have someone you know get a large group
of people put them on a carnivore diet
have a large group of people put them on
a keto diet have a large group of people
put on a standard american diet
let them eat burgers and fries and
chocolate shakes and sodas and let's
let's
let's find out what the [ __ ] it is put
people on a vegan diet i have had
tons of friends including sam harris who
was on a vegan diet and his
blood sugar was off the charts he had
tried was trying to figure out how to
stay healthy
like he tried he tried it for a long
time but he felt like
and then he went and switched to fish
and he felt like
just doing that too and then he went
back to me yeah now he's healthy the
answer
the answer always seems to come back to
being in the middle somewhere right like
somewhere we veer off so far and we're
like oh man we got doritos
and we got cookies and we got all this
stuff uh being thrown at us every single
day and it's
convenient and then somebody will say
okay you know no more carbs and you just
go the complete opposite route
and you end up with something like a
carnivore diet but i think just if you
were just sit there and think about
stuff logically
it would make sense to me that you can
overdo it on me like i think you can
overdo it on just about anything
yeah i that's why i lean towards balance
and that's why i like vegetables
but i can't talk you guys into that yeah
i think your balance is probably
is probably ideal but uh you know the
balance of the average americans not
great because i think they think
they can just grab and reach for
anything that's their level of balance
well i think the average america is just
trying to feed themselves you know
they're just trying to they're hungry
and they're tired
and look there's a great top
henry thoreau quote that most men live
lives of quiet desperation
and i think that applies to so many
different things and one of them is
work most people are working all day and
they're sad and they feel like
and when you get out there you're like
wendy's drive-through come on baby
hit me up with one of them double
cheeseburgers chocolate shake please
they get a little reward and you know
and then they feel even more
and then they crash and they get up and
they do it all over again with an egg
mcmuffin and
a cup of coffee with three scoops of
sugar in it and this is the
this is the roller coaster that most
people are on and it all started with
them going to bed too late
because they stayed around around on
their phone or watched tv
yeah they went to bed too late they woke
up later than they wanted they're tired
because they didn't get the sleep they
were supposed to get
they drank the coffee right and it's
just it's just one thing
snowballing after another also if you
want to have unstoppable confidence and
self love check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below do what you want to do do what the
[ __ ] is it that you
really want to do because if someone
else is doing it you can do it it's good
to treat other people the way you would
like to be treated yourself it's like a
golden rule and there's a reason for it
and that reason is that we're connected
the quality of your life is essentially
determined by
how you carry this one rule number three
try many things people should try
various diets and see what works for
them
and i think a lot of people get stuck in
this regimented thing where
and it can backfire on them too they're
carnivore so then when berries come in
season when people might watch this
towards the end of summer blueberries
gonna be in full swing does that mean
you totally avoid blueberries because
there's
i believe i'm not one of these people
that think plants are bad i think
blueberries the anthocyanidins and the
various and
you know antioxidants have a lot of
benefit to your microbiome into your
body in general
but then when you start to identify that
you're a carnivore or a keto or you're
vegan
then you close yourself down a little
bit so i think in your case
you don't have any major health issues
that i'm aware of you know that you've
talked about
so i would just continue what you're
doing but maybe in the winter
probably the best time to go carnivore
i'm going to say thank you
and here's i don't have i have one
health issue and that is
i'm dying so the only real question i
care about in every health theory
episode i do is how do i live forever
like if you're steering by how you feel
which is essentially what i do
i just don't know what its impact is on
longevity
um if a carnivore diet like if somebody
could tell me no no
a thousand percent if you do a carnivore
diet you're gonna live to 150. i'd be
all over the carnivore diet all day
every day i wouldn't even think about it
i'd never touch another
blueberry in my life like i would just
eat it um
but it's it's that big question mark
about longevity that winds me up
well let me pose this question to you
how could a diet be
negatively affecting your longevity if
it makes you feel better
that makes your sleep better if it
improves your heart rate variability if
it makes you stronger
if it makes you recover better how could
it slow down your longevity i mean or
affect longevity in a negative way i
don't know maybe i'm not thinking about
this through
properly but it doesn't make sense to me
rule number four
avoid diet coke with dr rhonda patrick
trump drinks 12 diet cokes per day
what can that do to a person's body then
they have a scientist on
or i'll tell you what it does to the
microbiome it like changes the
composition so that you're like
you're getting the kind of bacteria that
are really good at harvesting the
glucose from
from like the small intestine area and
it makes people like
become obese like that's dissociative
studies in people like that they've
shown that in people and then of course
they've done causal studies and animals
showing that
so the microbiome what's funny is that
people taking diet coke
are trying are trying to like improve
they don't they you know they don't want
the
refined sugar they don't want to have
the the constant insulin response and so
they're drinking the diet coke
it's kind of ironic that it's like it's
like making the more beat
obese by changing the gut microbiome now
is is it safe to drink just one can
every now and again
or is just something sure one can every
now and then it's okay
you know it's not i mean it's not gonna
like completely
not 12 cans a day or even one can a day
you're constantly going to start your
microbiome you're constantly going to
keep
shifting it and towards you know really
one can a day
probably yeah because it's the
microbiome is yeah
i like the way it tastes though diet
coke do enjoy diet coke i haven't had
diet coke
it's like 2006. i had one yesterday in a
hotel cracked it open
really yeah i haven't i really haven't
had one since 2006. it's cold yeah
i used to drink them i used to drink
them um
when uh for like in college and stuff to
stay awake and study for exams and all
that
but if you're taking something like that
um should you take a
corresponding like some sort of a
probiotic to try to combat that
i mean the problem with that is you know
the probiotics
which by the way there's all sorts of
interesting studies that have shown
effectiveness of certain probiotics that
are you know have a lot of
um that have live bacteria and a lot of
them but
you know in order for the probiotics to
work you either have to constantly take
them
or there needs to be space in your gut
for them to take residents in
right so if you're like filling your
body with all sorts of sugar or diet
coke and all this then
where where's the probiotic that you
you're taking in gonna
attach right so it's kind of flow
through and the flow through
has benefits but you have to keep taking
it right you know for that for that to
happen and so the
so really a healthy diet is the way it's
not you can't just counteract with
supplementation
healthy healthy diets the way i meaning
you know the the the
fermentable fiber which is what helps
grow helps the the commensal and good
bacteria
basically grow and thrive and rule
number five the last one before a very
special bonus rule
is listen to your body with sad good
food must be suitable for the body that
we eat
for it is for the body this is a
building material for this body the food
that you're eating
what is the appropriate food
unfortunately is all messed up
right now traditionally we ate very
sensible in this country
but this thousand years of innovations
have brought other kinds of food
cultures
and today the national diet is pizza or
pasta what is it which is one i don't
know
both were competing so we are losing our
sense about food
it's definitely time to look at what is
the most suitable thing if i go into
that food
it's a very long process but
you must experiment with food not just
by the tongue
but by the body you eat something today
and see just learn to observe how agile
and how active
your body feels after eating this food
if it feels like it wants to go to the
grave
that's not good food if it feels like it
wants to be alive after eating this
except coffee because that's a stimulant
if you eat food and your body feels very
agile and alive
that means it's good food body is liking
it if you eat something it feels dull
that means it's not liking it it's
having difficulty with it that's why it
feels dull
how can you say garlic is negative
garlic is good for my heart dissolves my
cholesterol
good for my blood pressure good for
digestion
even my doctor said i must eat garlic
if i can't eat garlic there are some
garlic extract
whatever pearls
see
so you need to understand this much
there is it is one thing to use
something as medicine
it is something totally different to use
the same thing as food stuff
yes garlic is a very powerful medicine
if properly employed
because it is medicinal if you just
consume it as a part of your food
you're definitely causing damage to the
system
in ayurveda you know what's ayurveda
in ayurveda it says every leaf
and every root found on this planet
has some medicinal quality in it
all the leaves and all the roots found
on the planet have medicinal quality
just a few we have learned how to use
rest we are yet to find out how to use
if this is so all you have to do is
whatever roots and leaves you can lay
your hands upon grab
them and eat them you will be very
healthy
fall time is great time for you
[Music]
see using a particular substance in a
particular way for a specific problem is
a different thing
just consuming something because it has
medicinal quality
doesn't make sense in fact anything
in the world can be used as medicine in
the right kind of hands
for example you heard of a cobra
you seen one a cobra's women
which is generally known to be deadly
poison
is used as a treatment for paralytic
conditions
in homeopathy you know what's home your
body that white ball treatment
you can use cobras venom as a treatment
for
paralytic conditions if you do not want
to get paralysis
the best preventive for paralysis is
you don't get cobras in north america
you have to import one from india
[Music]
and you keep one at home on alternate
days
one day right hand left hand right leg
left leg like this you
take a bite from the cobra on alternate
days
you will never get paralysis
it's the best preventive
[Music]
because only if you are there all these
problems come
if you are not there the releases won't
happen
using it in a particular way is one
thing just blatantly using it
is a completely different aspect
so even what is considered poison if
properly used
can be medicine but simply consuming it
as a part of your food
is not doing any good to you if you want
to know what kind of damage garlic is
doing to you
make an ounce of garlic juice and drink
it on an empty stomach
and see we'll have to take you to the
hospital for a stomach wash
that's the kind of reaction it will have
don't drink it
the same goes for onion make an ounce of
onion juice and drink it you will have
similar reactions in the body
but with the onion even when you're
just cutting the onion is the body
saying yes to onion or not onion
no body is saying no but you won't leave
it
because somebody has told you it's good
now i've got a really special bonus
script from dr oz on how to avoid
all unhealthy ingredients that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day
i wanna know what is the change that you
are now gonna make to your diet
let me know put your answers down in the
comments below and if you made it this
far in a video you're still here
watching i wanna celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos
we do something about it so that's you
and you commit you promise you're going
to take action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you among
the first five ingredients you shouldn't
find sugar
okay now sugar's supposed to be eaten of
course but it should come together with
either fat
uh or some element like fiber as you
would find in fruit so you can
you can absorb it a bit more slowly so
number one so sugar is
one of the first five elements in
whatever it is you're buying
it's a no-no no no you want to avoid it
okay now even worse than sugar
even worse than sugar is this look how
appetizing that is
and that is this is high fructose corn
syrup oh
that's what it is now it's not it's very
sweet yeah
but it's not very good for you it's not
good for you because it blocks the
ability of a chemical called leptin
which is the way your fat tells your
brain exactly
okay so you don't want this is the thing
that's blocking it and so you just keep
eating and eating
until you're literally stuffed right
it's not so much even the 150 calories
in the soda pop it's the fact that at
that same meal
you will normally consume an extra 100
calories of food than you would have
because of this because of this okay
high fructose corn syrup okay got that
these are both carbohydrates yes the
third carbohydrate
is this yes this is flour but it's
enriched white flour and rich why would
they enrich flour
the reason they enrich it is because
they already stripped out anything that
was worth a darn in it
and they add a little bit back so it
doesn't look so bad yes it should be
whole grain okay wave has those kernels
it has this b vitamins all the things
you want it to be in there whole grain's
hip it's in it's
in okay so these three are carbohydrates
yes let's move on down to the fun stuff
okay now big confusion about fats yeah
big this is animal fat yes animal fat
is saturated saturated fat is from
four-legged animals that's good
if it's coming from a four-legged animal
it's saturated
so that means these things can be solid
at room temperature
okay lard think lard bingo saturated
think large
good oils good oils our oil our liquids
at room temperature i'm repeating so i'm
putting it in my brain
okay now the thing about good oils is
they're not very stable if you put a
good oil into
a cracker and try to store it on a shelf
it goes bad
because good oils aren't very stable so
in order to deal with that problem
we took the good healthy vegetable oils
and we hydrogenated them
we added hydrogens to them okay tell me
that again we took good healthy oils
okay and in order to make them solid
yeah and make them so they wouldn't go
bad in a year on a shelf somewhere
uh-huh
we added hydrogens to them hydrogen
right
hydrogen okay makes those flimsy things
become rigid
and that's what'll make it stay on the
shelf for a year well it makes it solid
at room temperature
and solid on a shelf for a year okay and
that's this
ah wow this should be liquid
it's obviously not well this is very
good for your skin and
uh you can actually use this kind of
material for furniture polish
lots of fun things yeah but don't put it
in you i could use it on my feet
it's a dry feet good i'm thinking this
is a great moisturizer for the bottom of
my heels
this is nice yeah okay and this is what
what is this lard
uh no this this is actually hydrogenated
oil okay it's a material that
is is created so that you can keep that
stored material on the shelf for a long
time here's the big deal
when you have healthy oils yeah and you
cook with them
you oxidize them you damage them so the
key thing to know about the healthy oils
and what are the healthy oils olive oil
sesame
seed oil uh there's all the ones that
are liquid when they're flax seed oil
when they're
cold right some are better than others
but generally the ones i just listed
you know canola oil flaxseed oil olive
oil these are all very healthy oils but
because they're healthy they're very
delicate yes so you have to store them
in a refrigerator or at least cover them
so they stay dark
otherwise they will they will oxidize
they will go bad on you oh really so
this stuff is great because it doesn't
go bad but it's very bad for you
okay so the healthy oils if you learn
how to use them
take you a long way
put some on my heels and this is in
a lot of things this is the hydrogenated
oil correct yes this is
hydrogenated to make it solid okay and
then but the word that you will see
in the package is a trans fat because
these hydrogens
bring these molecules together and we
call them trans fats so i don't want the
thing to say hydrogenated and i don't
want it to say trans fat and i don't
want it to say saturated
exactly you just hit the nail on the
head
if you want an inspiring video to boost
your health check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there what are you eating because if
you're eating cheetos
and chocolate chip cookies for lunch
there's no way you're going to feel good
i don't care if you slept 12 hours the
night before
if you want to boost your immune system